let's jump to this story because it's in
a similar vein this is from the new york
post
charges against central park karen amy
cooper dismissed
you may be wondering to yourself what
does this story have to do with
masculinity in china and all that
everything
actually there's a story of women in
central park where she had her dog
not on a leash and this other guy whose
name was chris cooper strange they're
not related different names
and he was basically saying put your dog
on a leash she said no he tried offering
the dog treats she wigged out started
screaming saying you're threatening me
called the police
and she got arrested and charged with
filing a false police report
in order to get the charges dismissed as
the new york post reports
she underwent a psycho education at the
critical
uh what is it the critical theory center
or something like that
were they focused on equity
christian who is in no relation amy was
telling the woman to lease your dog
quote psycho education about racial
equity is woven into each therapy
session to prompt understanding and
reflection
a lizzie uh elizae orban told the judge
of amy cooper's time with the critical
therapy center in manhattan
miss cooper's therapist reported that
she was uh it was a moving experience
and that miss cooper learned a lot in
their sessions together
as if you would speak said no they're
going to basically explain this is about
racial equity training
that instead of going to jail she was
given the chance to go to the
you know critical therapy center the
critical therapy center to undergo
therapy sessions individualized psycho
education they called it
in china they enforce their ideology
which is china above all else they will
destroy you they will weld your doors
shut they will kidnap you in the middle
of the night and they will beat you
unless you are 100 for china
china is trying to make as luke
mentioned they're men more masculine
in the u.s we have similar things
they're now telling people to go to
re-education centers
instead of jail but they're beating you
down they're telling you to hate america
they're telling young men to not
be masculine and not be strong it's
flowing in one direction
a direction that ultimately results in
china taking over the world stage
becoming ultimate superpower and my
question to you is this
would you like to live under chinese
rules no
of course not of course not i love how
that's the direction things are going
seriously when the nba
when the nba comes out and you have
these stars being like hey man don't rag
on china they pay me a lot of money
in the pocket of the communist party
that means that you
your kids your family but you know what
here's the other thing that's happening
as you mentioned fertility rates are
down
people don't have kids to worry about
and they're not going to worry about it
in america we are i think we are being
exploited and extracted
i think the chinese communist party knew
thucydides trap was predicting a hot war
so they said
how can we make it so that people won't
fight a war well if they got if they
don't have kids they won't care to fight
this is really interesting kissinger
developed this concept of limited war
after world war ii in the 60s or
something
and basically they wanted to avoid a hot
war a total war in his words so
they've started making proxy wars
vietnam was a proxy war it was a limited
war
um iraq afghanistan limited wars they
don't want a total war with china
so now it seems like they don't even
want an armed war with china they just
want to make it a cultural war no china
doesn't want an armed war with us
they're beating us in a fourth
generation war right now
they're i think even the global banking
industry that's
carteling this arms race doesn't want a
hot war so if
just just just citing the san diego
paper that came out yeah
fourth involved insurgent groups fifth
involved psychological warfare
explicitly okay fine fourth and fifth
together but not only that
they uh have dumped a bunch of fentanyl
in our country
they're and designer drugs it's more
than that yeah where where are these
kids up in massachusetts getting their
drugs for
for their raids or for their waves they
go online and they order it and it's
made
in china we used to get ours from
holland it was much more fun back then
but
china is polluting our country with
drugs they're polluting our universities
with this communist marxist ideology
they're helping advance this agenda of
weakening our men they're taking over
transportation and infrastructure hubs
all around the world
they have co-opted they have co-opted
the the state sport of indiana
basketball if we don't even control
the highest expression of an american
homegrown sport like basketball anymore
i know it seems kind of flimsy if you
think about or just sort of not really
related
but it is what could be more related
than that they've captured an american
institution
well another thing to really think about
here as china's building power
grids all over the world ours is failing
as we're spending trillions of dollars
on wasteful wars like afghanistan
china's not doing that they're building
bases and building relationships with a
whole bunch of countries in the middle
east
as they're becoming the number one
trading partner with countries like iran
that they're trading oil for military
gear for and and when you see this kind
of presence when you see this kind of
prominence you really have to start
asking yourself what is the united
states doing
what they're doing they're doing a 911
style commission surrounding
the insurrection which is again another
waste of time nothing about helping the
people
increasing our wealth increasing our
health increasing our existence on this
planet
only more stuff that of course divide
and conquers us
and what's biden's number one policy
right now taking away
firearms disarming people making them
defenseless as he's going to go after
the second amendment soon
it's it's listen listen yeah it's all
just an indication of the collapse
i mean i mentioned this the other
episode there's a funny article from npr
it says the
uh national guard will remain in dc
until the fall
the fall so the fall is the season or
the fall
what we're emphasizing here and luke you
you mentioned it just now is a great
example
our institutions are not only failing us
but they're counterproductive in our
lives anymore institutions were meant to
give you
resources information structure health
meaning right they give you none of that
now
all of our institutions have been
co-opted and captured and if you listen
to what the institutions tell you if you
listen to conventional
wisdom where are you going to end up
well let's see nutritional pyramid oh
i'm going to be
fat oh go to college and borrow a bunch
of money oh i'm going to be in debt
oh get a job and down um chained to my
desk if you listen
to our institutions if you just listen
to what they tell you to do
it is a fact you will end up fat
sick chained to a desk and in debt for
the rest
with three masks on right yeah with
three masks
while you're alone when you're in your
own
chinese menu undergoing undergoing a
critical therapy session to correct your
bad behaviors because you dare to call
the police on something and take things
now three rushed experimental jabs as
now bill gates who also praised
china for their response to covet just
came out recently also today
and now is saying that people need three
shots of the coroner today
but think of utopia where the virus
wasn't the real goal
it was getting everybody the vaccine to
mark them for something else well well
are you talking about the original
utopia or the new one i'm talking about
the original i don't waste my time with
that
well the new one was was they canceled
it because
it was freaking people out because the
vaccine was sterilizing people
that's that was the spoiler i guess
spoiler alert that's the original one as
well yeah oh okay so
in the yeah in the new in the new show
they canceled it i guess because they
were like a lot of people were thinking
that
you know there's just some parallels
here listen i think
you know we have a right to be free of
cruel and unusual punishment
you commit a crime you pay a fine you go
to jail right
what what this story is of this woman
this caring and the therapy session
this is they they mention in the story
that they've already been doing with
other people
it's been happening they're giving you
an ultimatum
cruel and unusual punishment or jail
well because jail has become this like
because it's awful people are like give
me the re-education
treatment because i'll just do the
diversity training right bro people went
to vietnam instead of go to jail
this is an offer that has been made by
judges for all eternity
you can go do this terrible thing but in
this case it was go serve your country
in vietnam right it's a little bit
different they always give people
alternatives to go to jail i think
generally speaking we really don't want
people to go to jail sure finally
speaking
no it's like go have your brainwashing
yeah seriously right it's horrible yeah
i'm looking at medical therapists i'm
looking on twitter right now and people
want are wanting blood for for amy
cooper they're like
i'm pissed this is not enough this is
white privilege how dare she
the new york times the mainstream media
cnn are all writing articles about this
saying
this is this is not right she should
face punishment and i'm like this is
if if i remember this correctly this was
all a big misunderstanding you should
never call the cops
especially on a bird watcher but but i
do believe
correct me if i'm wrong that the
situation occurred because the bird
watcher said i'm going to do something
you don't like
she freaked out giving her and tried
giving the dog something she didn't know
what was going on hold on a second
if you guys some of my followers
remember when corona hit
i took my kids our weights we went out
in the front yard
oh yeah we lifted weights in my front
yard and my neighbor called the police
on me not just once
not just twice but three times okay
and now you're telling me that calling
the police on somebody
is a crime if the person is not
committing a crime should my neighbor
my neighbor needs to go to critical
therapy rehabilitation now
jack i think you're right she needs to
learn why she was being racist
she was black and i'm white so i'm not
sure that that's was this guy this bird
watcher
in africa a black i don't even like it
yeah yeah so he was like
we didn't even mention this well he made
a comic book about it and it's not a
different race the human race is one
race she tried
feeding her dog he tried coaxing her dog
away from her she freaked out
oh he was trying to get back at her for
not having on his leash well he said he
carried treats on purpose in the event
he found someone doing this so he was a
karen too
he's he apparently he refused to
participate in the trials because he
said the woman has already been through
enough she doesn't need punishment
yeah that's respectable yeah it was a
dumb
park argument that became some stupid
culture war moment
but i don't care about that i don't care
about the guy i don't care about the dog
i care for the fact that the judge said
go to a re-education center
yes to learn about equity because of the
race issue if he was a white dude they
wouldn't have said that i
know i think would have been on the
table no i think they still would have
is it a racial it would become a gender
issue
no it just if there was a white woman
maybe no no no it's worse than that it's
worse than that
critical race theory is now the baseline
right so anything can be addressed
by critical risk any conflict that you
have any perception you have of other
people
something bad that you did no matter
what if it's gender race whatever
abled-bodied who knows what related
critical racers captured all of our
institutions you can see it even
in like biology even in like physics
even james lizzie likes to point out
even in math so if two plus two is five
so of course it's in therapy as well
it's sad because if they remade monopoly
it would be like a chance card you could
get
get out of jail free card but it would
be we should uh play the race card
we should remake monopoly yeah not the
same way a racial justice monopoly no no
just like an updated kind of you know
similar game
you know sure the bank never runs out of
money well that they actually say that
in the rules
you know monopoly was made to be uh
anti-capitalist
oh i didn't know that why the original
the original monopoly was created by
this woman
and she wanted to create a game where
people would be really annoyed by
what was happening where the rich get
richer and then take everything that's
how it works
and that's why people flip the monopoly
that's happened to me before well so
then i guess uh uh
who was it hasbro or something or
whatever milton bradley i don't know
yeah some company bought it
or or i think that i don't think they
bought i think they stole it from her
like they just made their own version
and it's based on atlantic city so the
game was literally supposed to disparage
capitalism but i tell you
this is why nobody wants to play
monopoly because it always breaks down
to someone having power and just
oppressing the other players and they're
like
okay you gotta get the orange properties
there's something about rolling into
that
like 17 18 19. the red properties i
don't i don't know man
i was the odds are you're gonna get like
a 14 through 6 there's
16 through 19. there's on the dice the
game monopoly is solved
so it's a solved game meaning you can
win so long as you do these things every
time
and i don't it's been a long time since
i've been through the the theory of
monopoly but it's
buy all the red properties and never buy
hotels but buy all buy as many houses
you want three three houses on each
property that's why it scales up but
then no one can buy houses and if they
can't buy houses
and then the red properties are
statistically the most likely to get
landed on because of the
probabilities of the dice roll i always
liked orange because the houses were
only 100 bucks each whereas the red is
where it scales up to 150 any
any way not to get you know distracted
from game theory
a couple things i wanted to mention we
mentioned the uh coronal this is a
little off topic but i
i watched this project veritas fauci
interview with mark zuckerberg did you
guys get to watch the video
some of it yeah dude fauci's i don't
know if he's just too old or what but
this is an exact quote from fauci
uh zuck was asking him about the vaccine
and if it affects the dna and he was
like no
fauci's response was dna is inherent in
your own nucleus cell
he said that that phrase dna is inherent
in your own nucleus cell
this is dr fauci the preeminent
virologist what's the what's
it doesn't make any sense in your own
cell nucleus i think that's what he
meant to say
i i don't think that that matters i know
my bigger concern here is what
he's he's he's losing it dude and he's
supposed to be like the guy talking
about the bigger
the biggest right but the bigger issue
with all of that stuff playing back into
what we've been talking about is
our economy is being destroyed who
benefits china
our people are undergoing race therapy
trainings demasculization
and being told the country's bad
benefits china did you um ever study the
boxer rebellion
a little bit it's i wouldn't say study
but i've read about the end of the 1800s
basically the chinese rose up and tried
to push the british out of the country
in this box of rebellion i think in hong
kong right
yeah yeah um so the british had
basically
colonized eastern china and created an
opium trade and we're just
massively this is the east india trading
company i believe massive profiting they
were they were selling drugs to
opiates to the chinese and just
destroying the china
through through the opium trade and then
they they started hong kong i believe
was hong kong
and um were basically poised to take
control of china like they did india
they were gonna they were gonna
make it a british colony so the british
or the chinese eventually were like
the emperors i think at the time was
like no no hell no so they they rose up
and they attacked and just pushed the
british all the way back to the coast
murdered all these british people killed
him pushed him back to the island
and got rid of it and i think it seems
like they're using that as justification
to do that to us today not just
justification but an actual road map
opiates dude opiates they flooded our
country
they think i've talked with jack bosovic
about this a number of times
they think in time scales that we can't
comprehend
okay and they remember that from the
1800s like for real
and they have they had endured a century
of shame
yeah and now they want revenge for that
opiates are nasty i've taken them before
man they are hardcore
yeah and i was just my friend was like a
recovering heroin addict
and had um methadone and i was like yeah
i'll try it
you know i want to know i want to
understand and man it
it felt so good i i
not advocating no no i would never i
mean it's dead it was devastatingly
addictive the next day i asked him if i
could have more
and he said no yeah and he probably
saved me from an opiate addiction it was
so
felt physically so this is the thing we
need to understand especially with the
opioids this is
a thing that exploited our system to the
best of its abilities we're talking
about individuals who were in car
crashes had some pain
doctors were bribed and they gave out
this specific
medicine that was akin to heroin people
got addicted to it and what happened
they had to go somewhere else when the
doctors cut them off and that's when
they went into fentanyl
that's when they went into heroin and
i've even spent time in mexico well
this led them to the you know it was it
was it was this uh escalation like like
you said what was it the
the opiates you know fentanyl percocet
all the stuff yeah
ultimately leading to a more dramatic
result that was detrimental to their
lives
voting for donald trump yeah our medical
system was literally
yeah this is the bigger important point
here our medical system was
exploited by whether he called it the
pharma industrial complex or if you
believe there was a larger conspiracy
but people were told by their doctors by
the people who they were told to trust
take this pain pill it's okay they were
over prescribed it they then they became
addicted then they became hooked and i
had to go down to mexico i did this full
video
specifically highlighting a whole
treatment center about people recovering
from opioids in mexico because they
couldn't get the treatment in the united
states to get off the hardcore drugs
that they were put on by medical doctors
in the united states
so saying americans who just were
average americans that suffered car
crashes to have to go through this huge
pain
really makes you wonder institutionally
what's happening and as you mentioned
jack
every layer of our institutions screw
you over and benefit off of your
suffering
and anything that goes against the
institutions anything that goes against
the establishment gets cut now on social
media
it gets attacked by mainstream media and
they want to toe the line keep the line
making you suffer
forget it forget institutions build
networks did you know that
china underground labs are developing
new potent opiates
to send to the united states i mean it
only took me two seconds to google
search
it's from 2017. underground labs in
china are devising potent new opiates
faster than authorities can respond
and they talk about people in the united
states who are catching this finding the
stuff taking it
getting sick oding dying and it's being
manufactured of course
in china this is like legit a roadmap
this is the opinion
this is this is it's this is warfare
they are poisoning
us and it is it is through american
gluttony that it's happening
and so i've said this before i think joe
biden and
the democratic establishment and of
course the republicans are just
extracting as much as they can before
the ship
sinks they're the people in the titanic
running around grabbing as much of the
silverware as they can before they jump
onto a like joe biden you think is too
of course he is he just defended the
concentration camps
yes tony bob yalinski a family confidant
for the biden said he was crooked
and and and uh corrupted by china they
apparently got a
what was it a five million dollar
interest free loan to the to the buy to
hunter biden after joe flew his son on
government property
for a private deal why was the vice
president using government property to
fly a son out for a private deal for his
family
crooked and now he's defending
internment camps
come on man two plus two equals four i
mean imagine imagine being
a uyghur imagine being in taiwan right
now you'd be terrified of what's going
on right now
it's and they are they're protesting in
support of donald trump yeah sorry ian
going oh
you said interest free loan does that
mean they never have to pay it back
uh forgivable yeah interest-free
forgivable loan that was reported
well you know call it what you want it's
a bribe yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you